ein vermisstenfall ist jetzt ein
mordfall wo ist pia das haben wir heute
früh noch gefragt hier bei bild
die 25 jahre alte krankenpflegerin aus
greven in nordrhein westfalen die war
verschwunden spurlos nach der kirmes
dort in greven jetzt ist klar sie ist
tot die polizei hat ihre leiche gefunden
hier kommt nicht mehr zurück
schreckliche gewissheit im
vermisstenfall der 25 jährigen aus
greven sie ist tot ihr mutmaßlicher
mörder ihr nachbar
samstagabend war die altenpflegerin noch
mit ihrer besten freundin auf der kirmes
unterwegs spät abends ging sie allein
nach hause
sonntagnacht gegen etwa 42 erreicht sie
diese brücke
jaja emsbrücke in greven verliert sich
die spur von pia als sie am sonntag den
ganzen tag nicht zu erreichen war und
ihr handy aus war machten sich freunde
und familie schon große sorgen
50 stunden zwischen hoffen und bangen
die polizei im großeinsatz führt eine
gigantische suchaktion durch mit drohnen
und hunden doch kein lebenszeichen von
pia handys ausgeschaltet
montag nach dann ein erfolg ein 26
jähriger nachbar von pia verhält sich
auffällig er verstrickt sich bei seinen
aussagen in widersprüche
schließlich gibt er zu ich habe vier
getötet und die leiche versteckt
ermittler fanden die leiche der 25
jährigen in einem gebüsch im kreis
steinfurt ihr mutmaßlicher mörder pierce
26 jähriger nachbar sitzt nun in
polizeigewahrsam war verschmähte liebe
sein tatmotiv laut mordkommission soll
pia beziehungs absichten ihres nachbarn
abgelehnt haben und
wir sprechen mit bild reporterin katrin
weuster uns zugeschaltet aus gräben
katrina was weiß man genaueres über den
tathergang und über den täter
also wir wissen über den tathergang
einiges schon aber eben noch lange nicht
alles denn da ist die fia hat der
architekt am iss besucht die nach zwei
jahren nun endlich wieder stattfinden
konnte alle jungen leute aus den orten
hier um liegend waren quasi auf dieser
kirmes und die endet um 24 uhr bis um 2
uhr 50 ist sie noch gesehen worden diese
zeit dazwischen ist etwas unklar wo ich
jetzt stehe das sehen wir ist das
wohnhaus der jungen frau und
gleichzeitig das wohnhaus auch das
tatverdächtigen im erdgeschoss befindet
sich die wohnung des tatverdächtigen in
der etage darüber hatte pia gewohnt
beide schon einige zeit länger er so
ungefähr seit vier jahren sie seit einem
jahr die nachbarn haben jetzt nicht
deutlich mitbekommen dass die beiden
umgang miteinander gehabt hätten aber er
hat nicht ganz offensichtlich wer davon
versprochen so sagt es uns der staat
dann bald dass er versucht hat eine
beziehung aufzubauen
das hat sie abgelehnt das kam für sie
nicht in frage und offenbar hat er das
nicht verbinden können was weißt du über
die tatumstände also wie musste pia
sterben
wie er sterben musste ist noch nicht
bekannt es hat sich ja einige stunden
hingezogen bis der tatverdächtige
schließlich damit herausgerückt ist wo
man die leiche finden könnte das ist
dann gewesen in saerbeck auch hier im
kreis steinfurt mit dem auto ungefähr
eine viertelstunde entspannt hier ein
alba ein auto verfügt der verdächtige
auch das haben nach wann auch immer hier
gesehen das auto vielleicht hat man
gefunden die obduktion ist dabei
wahrscheinlich erst im laufe des
morgigen tages so dass zur todesursache
und zu den genauen umständen noch nichts
bekannt ist
[Musik]